Of course it smells like strawberries and dish soap. Now we've been through
the first two steps, and we've got a nice solution that's mixed up,
mashed pretty well, digestive protein. We need to move to our third step,
which is where we filter out all the unwanted chunks of strawberry that are
[SOUND]
left over. And this is when we're actually going to use our coffee
filters and second glass. So what you can see here, is I'm
going to take two coffee filters, mainly because one just isn't quite enough.
I'm going to place it inside the cup here. And then I'm going to take
[SOUND]
my strawberry mixture and I'm going to pour it
right here in the middle. Just like that.
Now I'm going to grab the coffee filters by both sides, and I'm just going
to lift up, and you'll see that
it's filtering through. This is liquid that contains
the salty DNA that's dissolved in it.
And all those big strawberry chunks are left
in the coffee filter. So I can squeeze the filter just a little bit, and
get even more out. Okay. Once you have
enough of this pink salty DNA strawberry liquid.
Then you're ready to go on to the next, and forth step, where we precipitate the
DNA, with alcohol. So I'm going to go to
the freezer, I'm going to get out our rubbing
[NOISE]
alcohol that we put in there so it's, nice and cold.